I already know when women say I'm
traditional in a sense it means I want
to be courted I want to know I want to
this is what they mean I want to be
courted like a traditional woman even
though I'm not one because I'm not a
virgin I'm not married before 25 I don't
have a cookbook oh but I cook one to two
times a week so yeah I'm traditional now
I'm like if you I swear to God if you
had a conversation with the actual real
traditional women oh my God and I I I've
been talking to them for this wife's
school oh my God they run circles around
us they make all their meals from
scratch from scratch they've been
raising kids and in a kid's like
situations where they're in charge of
children since they're like 16. they've
been either babysitting this woman had
10 foster kids wow that's that's a real
traditional woman she's growing at her
garden in the backyard oh my God what a
vegetables are fresh she's a virgin on
her wedding day I'm like I swear to God
I'm so excited to put everyone in the
same room because we don't even know how
bad we are until you see these women I'm
like look it and other do you meet many
traditional men
um
what do you mean I meet a lot of men
that
because we all meet men that want
traditional women but do we meet a lot
of traditions most men have Traditional
Values yeah yeah no I'm sorry I had to
think about this yeah yeah what kind of
what what makes a traditional man I
think most men want to be protectors and
providers and most men are capable of
protecting the average woman yes so most
of the men traditionally would want a
woman that doesn't work and they pay
every Bill and she doesn't come on
social media and doesn't do that is that
traditional question oh actually I have
I have a second part to this so a lot of
women will say I can't be traditional
because he doesn't make enough money I'm
finding out now this is wrong ladies
this is wrong you're wrong because you
actually this girl raised 10 children on
less than ten thousand dollars a year
it's because you want a lifestyle you
want a certain lifestyle you can't
afford you're trying to marry the
lifestyle instead of a family I'm just
I'm letting letting everyone know let
everyone in the red pill Community would
they say that they're traditional men or
they're not do you know what you know
what I'll say as well is um sometimes
people will say they're traditional men
will say they're traditional and they'll
put off the marriage thing because of
the finances but realistically if you if
you if you're Alpha and you just it's
like cool all our wedding yeah what we
can afford is this and this is what
we're doing because if we're getting mad
we're getting married it's not we don't
have you I know it's it's smart to have
this in place and and um like you wanna
you wanna move into the house straight
away afterwards but if you want to get
married you get married I think some
some women just get married for the
wedding anyway
I don't think that there's a such thing
as traditional men because I don't think
there's any definition of it I don't
think there's like any way you can sell
a man that they're traditional like with
a traditional woman you think oh yeah
like cooked spread and all that [ __ ] and
does like version and stuff so what do
you think about traditional matters
exactly I can't think of anything have
you gone on dates before yeah have you
paid for your meal yeah no no okay
that traditional manual not not the
2020.
pay for the food that's just part of it
and that's what you see how easy that is
compared to [ __ ] making a [ __ ]
easy paying for the milk no that's not
easy because you might have a good job
you hate for the rest of your life to
provide for a woman no but it's one type
of a card at the end of the day
so presses doesn't go behind baking the
cake and stuff I just feel like the
tradition based on the religion
an example of someone being a protector
if someone breaks into my house house in
the middle of night it's my job to go
out there and deal with the Intruder
it's not my wife's job that is someone
an example of being a projector
which doesn't involve anything to do
with money or anything else just pure
protection I'm willing to die to protect
my wife and my child and that's it
remember he said wife though not yeah
because one would go to war to protect
women not their wife
but women no okay but regardless how
guys really well how most guys who I
speak to how they weight thing to like
if you're my wife or you're my long-term
girlfriend you're all the benefits yeah
used to say this all the time yeah you
women want us to stand in front of
bullets for you and then you'll be rude
to us you'll talk you'll talk about us
generically yeah the majority of you
will will say that you're settling for
this kind of guy you talk about guys
like this [ __ ] but you want them to do
all these things for you men talk about
women like this okay
expected to go stand in front of a
bullet not for real so yeah
even even no no no it's not extreme
because even being a single woman in all
of human history it's a privilege we've
never gotten to do it like being being
able to sit on this podcast as a single
woman that is a privilege because who
who do you go to I think back then it
would be a privilege now it's normal
because okay okay think about it who
runs and you you've you've never heard
this content before she's she's just um
she got recruited off the street too
which is okay it's okay but like think
about it like who runs the
infrastructure of society the power
lines
the the garbage collector like
everything that makes Society run and
society would fall apart without the
police officers the firefighters they
tend to be men if we go if [ __ ] goes
south and we go to war it tends to be
men so right now men protect us and
provide for us just by being a single
woman in society because a lot of those
Industries are 98 men yeah but so my
thing is so does that mean that's a
traditional man what like does that
equal equate to a traditional man I mean
I would say a man that's willing to
protect and provide for his woman is
traditional I think most men are willing
to do that the problem is women want a
lifestyle that a lot of men can't afford
but that's on the women because they
want a lifestyle outside of their what
they would pick they would pick a
lifestyle over a family and I've talked
to girls about this where I'll be like
would you give up getting your nails
done for years no hair no makeup no none
no no new clothes nothing to in in order
to have a family like women used to do
that my grandma had 13 kids yeah I get
this is so awesome off of a fireman's
salary yeah I get the society thing that
we need men for certain roles but women
dominate education and education
determines doctors lawyers all the other
structures women also dominate child
rearing and with societies do not just
defined by infrastructure as defined by
what we the subcultures we create so
yeah like honestly the education system
has gone to [ __ ] since women took it
over so like there's actually negative
course like fun fact fun fact teachers
have a lot of standard deviation lower
IQ than the rest of the population
I agree because I was a teacher for many
years and I know that most teachers are
they don't have to have a high education
to be a teacher which is it's not to say
that women have no values to say that
women can live without men or no sorry
men can live without women but women
can't live without men that's the point
that's the whole point the human that
this is not no I think maybe from from a
society evolutionary standpoint I'm not
talking about emotional I'm saying you
get rid of reproduction Society would go
on and men would fill those roles where
women could not fill the roles that men
do we wouldn't we wouldn't have night
like the women wouldn't be rushing to be
plumbers we wouldn't be able to figure
out the powers
but you know even with that you're
forgetting that for men they have really
low standards of living if they're not
motivated by women I think Chris Rock
made a joke is our men would [ __ ] in a
box if it wasn't for women you kind of
without the motivation of women men do
not strive it's part of their ego boost
so without that do you think a man's
gonna be risking it all to build a
really tall building for what if he's
got no woman to provide for I mean
we're not arguing that like women like
men don't want women and when they don't
help Society the point is that women
don't or men don't need women for
survival women need men for survival
that's the point and being able being a
single woman is a privilege and as a
thank you we [ __ ] on them that's the
whole as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible